[Applaudissements]
chers amis au terme de cette journée je
voudrais vous remercier chaleureusement
pour votre travail depuis de nombreux
mois vous avez participé à ces
nombreuses conventions vous vous êtes
mobilisé vous êtes venu au siège des
républicains vous avez organisé des
débats dans nos fédérations sur les
valeurs de notre mouvement sur le projet
et vous avez vous êtes venu pour
débattre aujourd'hui de ce projet je
pense que nous montrons l'image d'une
famille moderne qui est capable de
débattre de discuter projet contre
projet idée contre idée c'est le temps
des idées le temps des hommes
viendra j'ai une conviction intime je
pense que 2017 sera la première élection
du nouveau monde car en peine en moins
de 10 ans nous avons av radicalement
changé de monde 2017 c'est sans doute la
dernière occasion pour remettre la
France dans la course de ce nouveau
monde remettre notre pays dans la course
c'est d'abord regarder la réalité en
face telle qu'elle est regarder le monde
dans les yeux et bien mes chers amis ce
nouveau monde c'est d'abord un monde
dangereux et chaotique un nombre heurté
façonné par les crise où l'instabilité
et la volatilité deviennent la norme un
monde où le terrorisme aveugle nous en
avons parlé ce matin peut peut frapper à
tout instant à Paris à Bruxelles à
Orlando ou à Istanbul c'est un monde où
les crises économiques politiques
financière se multiplient et se succède
à un rythme vertigineux regardez en
moins de 10 ans nous nous avons connu la
crise des subprimes nous avons connu la
crise de l'euro nous avons connu la
crise argentine nous avons connu la
crise chinoise nous avons connu la crise
des Bourses asiatiques nous avons connu
la crise de la Grèce la crise en
Portugal et en Espagne et bien mes chers
amis le monde s'est emballé nous avons
connu la crise des matières premières
qui subissait une inflation qui avait
des conséquences dévastatrices pour les
pays développés et bien nous vivons
aujourd'hui une déflation des matières
premières qui a des conséquences
dévastatrices pour les pays émergents ce
nouveau monde c'est un monde extravagant
où les cartes sont rebattues en
permanence aussi bien sur le plan
économique que politique on peut émerger
ou disparaître en un rien de temps
regardez sur le plan économique en moins
de 10 ans les fameux Google Apple
Facebook Amazon ont un poids équivalent
à celui d'un pays comme le
Danemark regardez les 100 premières
entreprises dans le monde elles
produisent l'équivalent de la richesse
de la première puissance économique
mondiale les
États-Unis regardez comme la
Californie la moitié des habitants de la
France a doublé à dépassé le PIB de la
France il y a quelques mois regardez la
valeur des 10 premières marques
mondiales je dis bien les marques qui
qui pèse autant que le CAC 40 la
capitalisation de nos entreprises
françaises sur le plan géopolitique là
aussi vous avez en permanence des
turbulences le Japon était la grande
puissance économique des années 80 elle
a connu 20 années de
stagnation le Nigéria sera la trème le
3ème pays le plus peuplé dans le monde
dans seulement 20 ans le Brésil il y a
seulement 5 ans était l'économie
montante émergente il traverse la crise
économique et politique la plus grave de
son histoire mais ce nouveau monde mes
chers amis c'est aussi celui de
l'accélération exponentielle du progrès
technique où la réalité a d'ors et déjà
dépassé la fiction si on veut préparer
un projet pour le monde de demain il
faut d'abord être conscient de cela
n'ayons pas la mémoire courte
l'invention du smart
tactile c'était en 2007 l'année
prochaine l'année prochaine un habitant
de la planète sur de en sera équipé
90 % des données qui sont aujourd'hui
stockées dans le monde ont été créés
depuis moins de 2 ans ça on dit long sur
l'enjeu des Big Data du stockage de ces
données de leur
propriété le développement et
l'interprtation des des nanotechnologies
des biotechnologies du numérique des
sciences cognitives est en train de
repousser chaque jour davantage les
limites de la recherche et de
l'innovation ça a des conséquences sur
notre vie quotidienne ça a des
conséquences sur la production
industrielle sur la production agricole
sur la santé sur nos déplacements sur la
gestion de nos administrations demain et
bien mes chers amis n'ayons pas peur de
ce monde du 21e siècle je considère que
l'élection de 2017 c'est d'abord se
préparer préparer la France à ce nouveau
monde et la vérité c'est que la France
elle n'est pas préparée à ce nouveau
monde notre pays nous l'avons dit à
plusieurs reprises depuis ce matin il
décroche de manière aigu se montrant
chaque jour davantage inadapté à prendre
à capter la vague de la
mondialisation il s'accroche à un modèle
qui est plus proche du 19e siècle que
celui du 21e siècle écoutez regardez ces
défilés auquels nous avons assisté
pendant tout le mois de juin où toute
l'Europe se tournait sur Paris il me
revenait le bon mot de Jean dormaesson
qui disait les syndicats aiment
tellement le travail que quand ils
organisent une grève ils appelle ça une
journée
d'action c'est cela aujourd'hui l'image
de la France la société française est
fossilisée elle est bloquée elle est
cadenacée elle est corseté par 10500
lois 127000 décrets 400000 normes un
code du travail de 3000 pages des
milliers d'instructions fiscales des
formulaires SERFA par centaines et 57 %
de dépenses publique mais ça s'explique
mes chers amis ça s'explique parce que
la France est quand même le seul pays
qui impose aujourd'hui à ces entreprises
une invraisemblable un invraisemblable
choc de complexité avec un dispositif de
pénibilité absolument unique au monde
écoutez on va devoir mesurer la charge
au travail l'angle d'inclinaison du
travailleur s'il est à 45 degr ou pas si
c'était bien homologué par un arrêté
rédigé par la branche professionnelle
tout cela évid
sous l'gide d'une loi dirigée par le
ministère du travail et des affaires
sociales et bien mes chers amis moi je
constate une chose c'est que pendant
qu'on ajoute des contraintes à nos
entreprises les travailleurs détachés eu
ils travail et il semble très détaché de
la
pénibilité la France est le seul pays où
les députés socialistes tient dans le
dos des
entreprises de rendre public un
reporting fiscal livrant des
informations stratégiques à leurs
concurrents étrangers c'est la loi Sapin
2 mes chers amis la France est le seul
pays qui prétend réformer le droit du
travail en dilant avec les syndicat des
milliers d'emplois protégés dans nos TPE
dans nos PME et maintenant dans nos
entreprises de franchise c'est un
scandale c'est la loi elcomerie la loi
elcomerie c'est la
dans toutes les PME vous avez aimé la
CGT à la SNCF vous aurez la CGT dans
toutes les PME de
France la France mes chers amis est le
seul pays où pour financer des
compétences économiques confiées aux
régions pour accompagner le
développement des entreprises on crée
une nouvelles taxes sur les entreprises
on va prélever de l'argent aux
entreprises le redistriu à l'état qui va
le redonner aux régions qui le redonnera
aux entreprises bonjour l'absurde la
France mes chers amis est le seul pays à
vouloir faire fuir les sièges sociaux
des grands groupes enfin écoutez
regardez objectivement les choses le
siège de La Farge est parti en Suisse le
siège d'Alcatel est parti en Finlande le
siège d'alsom part aux États-Unis
heureusement le siège de la CGT lui
reste bien à
monreil
une chose est sûre la France ne
construira pas son futur ne bâtira pas
son avenir avec les socialistes des gens
du passé des gens
dépassés la philosophie économique des
socialiste de ce gouvernement a
d'ailleurs été assez bien résumé par
notre ancien Premier ministre actuel
ministre des Affaires étrangères
Jean-Marc h je cite je préfère être
chômeur en France qu'avoir un petit
boulot en Allemagne ou en
Angleterre
effrayant le Premier ministre lui il
préfère écouter le président de l'Unef
qui a 27 ans est toujours en 3e année
d'économie sociale et solidaire plutôt
que le prix Nobel d'économie pathétique
enfin le président de la République fin
de quinena aidant le voilà pris d'une
surenchère frénéthtique de promesses
démagogiqu françois Hollande s'est
transformé en joueur pathologique on a
le sentiment que plus il échoue plus il
rate plus il descend dans les sondages
plus il distribue plus il augmente la
mise rien de l'arrête la prime pour les
enseignants la hausse du point d'indice
des fonctionnaire la garantie jeune et
maintenant la baisse d'impôt de 2
milliards d'impôts sur le R u open bar
on a l'impression que c'est un joueur
invétéré un joueur de casino tant que je
perds je joue je vais toujours me
refaire il a transformé l'État en casino
Hollande c'est Casino
Royal
face face à tant d'incompétences tant
d'improvisation tant de mauvaise fois
notre responsabilité à nous les
républicains elle est immense et je
pense sincèrement que le projet que vous
venez d'adopter il est à la hauteur de
ce défi et nous avons les clés pour
réussir nous les avons à une condition
et je voudrais pour terminer vous faire
partager cette condition cette condition
c'est que nous soyons capable de changer
de logiciel et je voudrais décrire avec
vous le contour de ce nouveau logiciel
ce logiciel pour faire entrer la France
dans la la course du monde du 21e siècle
il doit d'abord systématiquement miser
sur l'agilité et la réactivité il faut
être plus rapide que les voisins dans
toutes nos politiques publiques il faut
être plus réactif il faut être plus
compétitif les Britanniques sortent de
l'Europe et bien si ça pouvait nous
servir à définir une politique fiscale
pour les entreprises financières à
supprimer la taxe sur les transactions
financières à supprimer la taxe sur les
salaires des banques et des assurances à
assouplir le régime des impatriés à Sup
l'F et si on transformait la gif en
caresse deuxème exemple de ce logiciel
promouvoir toujours le risque plutôt que
la rente écoutez nous nous devons être
du côté des entrepreneurs de ceux qui
créent pas du côté de celui qui tésorise
à cause de notre fiscalité au capital
délirante ayez en tête mes chers amis
qu'en 10 ans nous avons perdu 4 millions
d'actionnaires individuels dans notre
pays
la France elle doit aussi les
républicains ils doivent également
garantir des chilets de sécurité si vous
donner plus de liberté il faut plus de
sécurité plus de liberté il faut plus de
protection sur le marché du travail la
meilleure des sécurités c'est la
formation la logique voudrait que ça ne
devrait pas être un drame de perdre son
emploi à condition qu'on soit sour d'en
retrouver un c'est ça le système que
nous devons inventer ensemble les
républicains ils doivent être du côté du
progrès la France est une nation
d'inventeur la France a inventé la
machine à vapeur la photo le cinéma
l'automobile l'aviation les vaccins et
bien avec le principe de précaution la
France a donné le sentiment d'avoir
perdu sa curiosité sa foi dans la
science on m'a reproché à cette tribune
d'avoir parlé des OGM je constate que
109 prix Nobel dans le monde vienne de
nous dire d'ouvrir les yeux et bien
notre devoir à nous les républicains
c'est d'être du côté des chercheurs du
côté des
scientifique enfin notre logiciel il ne
doit pas oublier la
proximité plus le monde est global plus
nous devons nous modernisons nous
moderniser plus nous devons être proche
des gens plus nous devons consolider les
structures de base la famille la commune
tout ce en quoi les gens se
reconnaissent ça doit être au cœur de
notre projet des républicains mes chers
amis il nous reste 10 mois comme disait
Baudel le temps est court et l'art est
long 10 mois qui doivent être consacré à
un travail de pédagogie intense nous
allons avoir besoin de vous parce que
ces 10 mois vont être consacrés à
établir notre plan de conduite du
changement c'est une question
d'efficacité c'est aussi une question de
crédibilité la situation du pays
ressemble sans doute à bien des égards à
celle que le général de Gaulle a trouvé
en 1958 et bien notre responsabilité à
nous les républicains pour remettre la
France dans la course elle est immense
le monde appelle la France mais le monde
n'attend pas la France personne ne nous
attend alors à vous membres du Conseil
national je vous demande de redoubler de
pédagogie sur les opportunités qui se
dessinent pour ce nouveau monde pour que
la France retrouve sa place dans ce
monde à vous cher candidat mon cher
Nicolas cher François cher Alain cher
Bruno ou que vous soyez et bien je vous
dis simplement faites en sorte que la
France entre ce nouveau monde faites en
sorte que la France soit de
retour